hey sebastian lilly good to see you hey
nice to see you let the adventure begin
i i just watched the whole series last
night and i have to say
why didn't tommy lee just pay the
electrician off the top none of this
would have happened right
so you're gonna have to ask him now
i know you gotta ask him i you you guys
are absolutely amazing the the
transformation is so bang on the
mannerism the voice all of it
congratulations to both of you and lily
for you two you really absorbed yourself
into this character i mean how would you
describe pam now what you know now and
her life in the 90s
well i mean looking at it from and
outside and just to be in the to be that
well i mean she was the biggest one of
the biggest stars on the planet i mean
from baywatch like and an icon and so to
to sort of have as a young woman i can
just think of it from like my
perspective if i imagine myself in it as
a young woman with that much amount of
attention and then for this huge sort of
violation to take place just try to
imagine the strength it would take and i
and i really think that it it must have
and it did and i i admire hugely i
really do
yeah and how cool was it for you to be
pam in that red swimsuit as big watch
like that was literally never come on
for me usually i'm massively
self-conscious wandering around a beach
drawing lots of them
so that was definitely a leap of
imagination for me to own that but um
i'd worked really hard with an amazing
trainer and i and i loved getting that
fit it was really empowering oh you
looked fantastic and you too sebastian i
mean you were in tommy lee's glory i
mean you tattoos and being free in the
house to episode two talking to his
you know
that came out from his biography like
it's it's great to see you in this
character what did it feel like for you
to bring him to life on screen compared
to i don't know bucky barnes from
winter soldier
uh well certainly certainly a very
different uh challenge very different
task um
again uh i'm pretty sure that that bucky
barnes doesn't have any tattoos
so uh that in itself was uh was sort of
an interesting kind of uh
kind of challenge to sort of uh
even get even get the look right and
trying to lose weight and go running
every day and not eat for 18 hours a day
and
obviously the drums in themselves were
were a whole task but um but again we we
had a great team and we had super
support and there was a hair makeup team
that were
so prepared and they knocked it out of
the park and and we just sort of had to
kind of like
keep keep following the footsteps uh
ahead of us and and we were fine
well i mean doing a project like this
what what did you guys learn about
yourselves as actors and and your sense
of being i mean i think there was a
point where you said you were frightened
lily taking on this role i mean what
what did you get out of this
i got a lot out of it actually it was um
it was definitely the biggest acting
challenge i've ever had in my life for
both of us and but i definitely i think
we really
we lent on each other and i really
enjoyed um acting with sebastian he's so
kind of
impulsive and
it was a really wonderful
scene partner it was really pushing me
and so i felt like and with craig
gillespie to start directing us it was a
it felt really alive i really loved that
yeah it was i mean and i feel vice versa
with her i mean again um the writing was
just really really good the scripts were
really great and and i feel like that
they got the tone they got the the sort
of
cadence and and was in the dialogue for
for both of them and and
um
you know i think i think pers
perseverance is isn't it yeah it's a
good word because that's a good word
yeah five days a week and then coming to
be in the makeup trailer like three
hours at 3 30 on monday morning to to go
and shoot for 10 hours pretty intense
scenes like and then to go home at night
and you've got your own life waiting for
you and you have to show up for that
it was it's an interesting balance um
but i think we both
probably feel stronger now yeah i reckon
i could now take it on him yeah better
than i did
that's the thing at the end
it comes and it goes and then you go oh
i was just you know yeah
yeah i could just jump in
and lily you know we know pam there
hasn't been that if she's gonna watch it
or not but what will it mean to you that
she does watch it and what do you want
her to get out of it
oh i don't know it's hard for me to
speak to that or to you know respond
because that's so her own i would i
would wait to hear whatever if she ever
chose to speak out what that would be
but um i i definitely
wanted to play her authentically and i
and i i worked hard and i i hope that i
hope that what we set out to do in the
show which is to to look at what
happened with with the theft the crime
of this tape being stolen from them but
also to look at the bigger picture of
the repercussions and how it's impacted
us on our and our kind of culture today
so i hope we achieve those goals because
that's what we were setting out to do
and did you ever thank you so much to
both of you congratulations thank you
you